hands up for a healthy heartbeat
yeah
my guest co-host jeannie mai jenkins
getting down in her 32-week checkup so
we know the baby's healthy but you still
don't know what you're having i don't
want to because i realize nichelle how
many surprises do you actually have in
life true this is the ultimate one and i
want to have a gender-free planning with
my husband so everything that we're
excited to do should apply to the child
no matter if it's a boy or girl do you
think it's a boy or do you think it's a
girl i will tell you jeezy straight up
thinks it's a boy he thinks boy okay and
you've been sharing just the sweetest
belly shots but i understand you don't
like your tattoo what's going on with
that so
a lot of people don't know this but i
have a tattoo on my belly button and i
got it when i was 15 years old okay
because i promised myself i wouldn't
have a child the thing is the size of a
banner on a bus
i need everybody all the tattoo removal
artists anybody who's got
recommendations please send them my way
because as soon as this bakes out i got
some work to do okay you announced your
pregnancy i saw that too on the real yes
yeah i am pregnant
so what's it like experiencing this
chapter of your life with them
this that's a great question because
we've been going strong for eight
seasons and for the seven seasons i've
told the ladies i will never have a baby
so i always
listened from that angle and i still
really want to protect women's choices
you know it's never okay to just
pressure a woman but to go through
a whole life transformation because of a
relationship and because of growth and
and evolution
i'm learning this in real time it really
was jeezy and your relationship that
made you say
no i i gotta do this i gotta do this and
i have to do this with this man yes i
absolutely i think meeting somebody with
such a maturity and such a beautiful
vision on life you can't help but to
trust meeting somebody where you could
actually
learn what a healthy relationship looks
like things grew from that soil oh can
we talk about mama mai please how did
you tell her and what did she say
you told her she was gonna be a grandma
grandma she didn't say much because as
soon as grandma mai learned that we were
pregnant
she moved into the house without
anybody's permission
i'm this is a actual factual she flew in
landed at two in the morning my husband
opens the door for her sees not one not
two but like five luggages wigs lashes
whole outfit changes seasonal colors and
he was like how long is she here for
again and i was like
two days four four days a week he's like
no no you need to have a talk because
this is this is definitely like a
collection of years this woman is
planning to be in this and she hasn't
left you no no so that is a talk we're
going through it right now i'm just
learning that we also have to set
boundaries yeah so there's gonna be a
balance somewhere exactly by the way you
are glowing and i love what you're
wearing today inc macy's and reunited we
together came up with a collection that
for me had to be size inclusive had to
be transformational with whether you're
pregnant or not had to be something that
you could wear for all facets of life
and so all of the genie my collection i
inc is available at macy's and it's
something for every moment in your life
whether you're going to be a boss or
just lounging around feeling comfortable
in your skin i got you
[Music]
you